[Music]
Brainiac was obvious it made absolute
sense that he would be our big bad it
moves from planet to planet it's known
as the collector of worlds its true name
is brightly
to meet Jeff Jones and Gary Frank did an
incredible run on Brainiac we really
decided to take a run at making him
colder and more emotionally distant and
ancient and that version of Brainiac he
did heavily influence what we're doing
in the show and his crazy scholarship
which is really cool on iconic brainiacs
never been seen before like this some of
Krypton
[Music]
this is Krypton and this is the story of
the house of El my name is Adam strange
someone from the future is coming to
destroy Krypton
because what grandson becomes the
greatest hero in the universe
we are not alone in the universe
you files known as the collector of
world's finest remain is brainy help me
find a way to stop it you have to find
the fortress rip candle from the ground
and enslave all of us you fight with
honor and fight without mercy
once this Cape is gone our times up
Superman Belov my true existence hey
everybody is Charlie we have to freak
out about Brainiac here they finally
confirmed that he's the big bat of the
show I think we all had suspicions when
we saw that last trailer and you see
those tendrils floating from the corner
of space like oh those look like the
tendrils of brainiacs skull ship and
albeit this version looks very in just
to see it's always interesting to see
where their visual inspiration comes
from because a lot of the functional
design of Krypton comes from DC EU and
that Zack Snyder prequel seen from Man
of Steel but it looks like they're also
pulling a little bit from the injustice
universe just a more hardcore take on
the Superman mythos because we also got
that other version of Brainiac 5 on
Supergirl
which looks completely different so
after posting this picture really early
this morning it seems like immediately
people were more on board
with this version of Brainiac I think
just because he looks a little closer to
comic book Brainiac so if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I will
be doing Krypton videos just depending
on interest level so if you guys want me
to do videos for every episode with
comic book Easter eggs or just a couple
videos no worries as long as you click
that Bell and enable alerts you'll get
all the videos obviously things start
March 21st so it's still little ways
away but Krypton is gonna be a Wednesday
night show so it's not gonna conflict
with any of the flash or arrow videos or
any of the other DC TV stuff that I do
and there is actually a little bit of
news about Titans and Nightwing and all
that stuff but I'll mention that at the
end of the video because it's not
totally relevant to what's going on on
Krypton so the really important thing
that you probably notice when they're
talking about Brainiac is the comic book
panels that they showed you so if you
want to know which comic book run to
read to prepare for this I would
recommend starting with Geoff Johns New
Krypton arc which was actually a while
ago it happened way before convergence
and then also read a little bit of
convergence Brainiac because that's when
they sort of turned him into the
collector of worlds like for the most
part he's known as Brainiac there's a
couple iterations depending on which
time period you're set in like he
continues to upgrade himself and then
when Geoff Johns got to this new Krypton
arc he sort of reinvent himself over and
figure the collector of worlds the
convergence run that happened right
before DC's big rebirth event did that
again made him even more ancient sort of
existing outside of space-time in a much
bigger figure so it seems like this
version is just a combination of that
New Krypton Brainiac injustice Brainiac
and then convergence Brainiac so like
his skull ship is much bigger than
traditional brainiacs skull ship it
looks much more ancient really Haggard
this version of Brainiac might be the
version that we pick up with immediately
when the show starts before he starts
messing with the timeline Terminator
style so if you haven't seen any of the
promos you don't know what's going on
the basic premise of the show is the
Terminator Skynet style Brainiac wants
to get rid of Superman because he gets
his ass handed to him so many times so
his solution is to go back into
Krypton's history mess with the house of
El to erase Superman from present-day
so atom stranger who's holding
Superman's cape and telling him you need
to help save your grandsons a legacy and
he's explained who Superman is basically
who are you talking about my grandson
what the hell's going on it sounds like
he doesn't even know that much about the
fortress of solitude that they're
standing in here the really cool thing
about the show the season one is only 10
episodes Brainiac changes Superman's
history erases him from the timeline
season 1 is all about preventing or
fixing that change they said that you
know Terminator style their changes to
the timeline won't completely reverse
things like when Barry fix flashpoint he
didn't fix everything like you can't put
everything back the way you found it
time just doesn't work that way there
are always ripples there we go
things are back to how there should be
well for me anyway for you well I guess
you'll just have to wait and find out so
whatever they do in the finale this
season is going to change the timeline
just a little bit so imagine they fix
the timeline but create an injustice
situation like they won't perfectly fix
everything at the end of season one like
Superman might come back but also be a
really twisted version of himself I
don't know how they're gonna use him on
the TV show I might just use the titles
of my episode videos is like Superman
Krypton just to let people know that
this is actually a Superman prequel
because I think most comic book people
know immediately what you're talking
about when you talk about Krypton but I
am a bit dubious about the awareness of
just regular TV show Watchers there's a
lot of people that just watch the TV
shows and don't read the comics so no
worries we'll figure it out as we go
along but the major thing about the
series that they revealed recently is
that the city where this is all taking
place wait for it is Kandor city which
is why i immediately thought brainiac a
while ago like before they announced him
I'm like well they're doing Kandor city
the big battle looks kind of like
Brainiac they're probably doing Brainiac
I love the imagery of it actually
already being bottled up now this which
looks like a city shield it doesn't look
like it's actually been shrunk down so
this might be what it looks like while
it's on Krypton but if you're not
familiar with Kryptonian society they're
ruled by an oligarchy so this ruling
council is just made up by people of the
most powerful houses so your family's
political power is directly tied to the
standing your family is in and when the
series picks up because of Brainiac
smashing ations the house of El kind of
sounds like it gets thrown under the bus
and if you recognize Barristan Selmy
here he actually plays the protagonists
grandfather so this is Sehgal he's
Superman's grandfather when the series
picks up he's close to Clark Kent's age
at the beginning of Smallville probably
a little bit older he's in a
relationship with Lita Zod who's part of
the military guild if you're at least a
little familiar with Kryptonian
backstory the house of Zod is largely
part of the military guilds so most
houses tend to belong to a single guild
like a family just has a certain level
of tradition like oh I've always been
part of this guild so my children will
become
part of this guild so Barristan Selmy is
playing his grandfather and he is the
person to first start pushing into
phantom zone technology so like for
instance they have Fort Rozz as a
location on the series but at this point
in the timeline it's still being used as
a traditional military base if you watch
Supergirl they actually brought the
actress that played Ursa from the
Christopher Reeve Superman films back
for an episode
it was literally titled for Rozz you
know I am and yet you ask uncertainty
will be your doom not greenstone but
eventually what happened is is before
the destruction of Krypton jor-el
perfected Phantom Zone technology and
they started using that to house all
their criminals so fort Rozz became this
old relic prison where they just left
people to rot and it would just orbit
around Krypton so that's how they used
it on the Supergirl TV show we've talked
about Adam Strange he's from present-day
obviously something happens and he
recognizes that Superman was erased from
history so he races back into Krypton's
past using Zeta beam technology to warn
seg L about what happens to Superman and
Katara's explained to him why it's so
important that he fixed the timeline the
way they talk about the fortress of
solitude is that it's been in their
family for a long long time in their
ancestors at various points were
inventors it just houses all of their
creations but let me know what you think
of Brainiac I don't know which networks
are airing the show internationally so
if you live in a country where it's not
available you'll just have to seek other
means for finding the show I think we
all know what that means I'm working on
some more black panther to Wally West
flash related stuff why you wait for
that click here to learn about why Black
Panther and spider-man are a key to
Marvel phase four and click here for my
brand new flash video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight